Taylor Swift versus Katy Perry is there
bad blood finally over but as one Taylor
feud ends she goes on stage and
reignites another plus
so now Lathan is speaking out on that
bizarre Beyonce biting rumor after
teasing fans for weeks from tour
rehearsals Taylor Swift's reputation
stadium tour officially kicked off
Tuesday night in Glendale Arizona but on
the night full of surprises the biggest
shocker came courtesy of Taylor's
one-time frenemy Katy Perry who sent her
a pre-show give a peace offering if you
will seemingly ending any bad blood
between them so I just got to my
dressing room and found this actual
Olive Branch this means so much to me
Katy sent Taylor a literal Olive Branch
now for those who don't know that's a
symbol for peace and while the note is
not fully legible we managed to decipher
some of Katy's message quote hey old
friend I've been doing some reflecting
on past miscommunications and the
feelings between us I really want to
clear the air I'm deeply sorry these two
have been at each other for years and if
you've been even remotely following
their feud or the respective districts
then you know this is a big deal so the
question is why now well a source tells
us Katy put a lot of thought into her
personal sweet apology quote Katy took
time to write a kind note in hopes
Taylor would see how much she cared
about putting this behind them she's
done holding on to the past and she
wants to set a good example for women
our source adds Katy hopes they can
finally support each other's music and
maybe one day soon even hang out
together gasp don't you think Taylor
should put Katy in the this is why we
can't have nice things video I'm
predicting we won't be seeing any girls
night anytime soon but you know what
it's a start now but for Taylor it seems
it may take a bit longer to forgive and
forget when it comes to the Kardashians
though the 28 year old singer had the
crowd in Arizona shook after night one
of her reputation tore her stage was so
over-the-top there was literally giant
snakes everywhere and Taylor told the
audience quote you might be wondering
why there are so
any snakes or a few years ago someone
called me a snake on social media not
someone like Lee Kim Kardashian who
tweeted this in 2016 and then of course
Kim fans trolled Taylor's Instagram with
that snake emoji but it wasn't all shade
during the show Taylor also surprised
the crowd by bringing out her tour mates
Camilla Kibeho and Charli XCX to help
her sing shake it off
well as tailors relationships grow
stronger another one might be done for
good because Rihanna and Drake have
unfollowed each other on Instagram yep I
checked and it is true the two are not
insta homies anymore and while it's
unclear when they unfollowed each other
the revelation comes after Rihanna told
Vogue they aren't friends anymore and
that his VMA speech to her made her
uncomfortable why she had a drag Drake
like that is beyond me but it seems like
they really are trying to cut each other
out I gotta say that kind of bums me out
not gonna lie but they'll find their way
back to each other just like Ross and
Rachel I'm calling it right now all
right in other news
so now Lathan is speaking out about
those rumors she bit beyonce the love
and basketball star covers health
magazines June cover and inside she
tells the Mack she thinks it's crazy
people think she would take a bite out
of beat quote I think it's the most
absurd thing I've ever been involved
with
thank God I've been in this business for
20 years and have had so many rumors
about me they used to devastate me in my
20s but in order to survive survive in
this business you just have to let it
roll so not as she adores beyond saying
I would never do anything malicious like
that to her and calls the whole thing
bizarre well when this story first began
to swirl two sources told et it was
Sanaa who playfully bit Beyonce at an
after-party following jay-z's December
concert one source said they didn't
believe it was malicious or anything
just that it caught Beyonce off-guard
and she didn't like him so now
previously denied the accusation so
we'll just have to leave this unsolved
mystery to someone else because they
ain't nobody got time for this and
that's all the tea I have for you guys
today so thanks so much for watching and
thank you for watching our Met Gala
recap if you missed it you can click
right over here
for the heavenly fashions tomorrow the
daily deni will be live here at 12 p.m.
Pacific so I'll see you guys
[Music]